bonsoir romain et qui encore au bureau
le soin d'éviter un dîner avec les
beaux-parents cacher une nocivité ou
encore préserver votre jardin secret
oslo détendez vous on s'occupe de tout
notre société cartonne j'ai rencontré
l'amour en bref tout allait bien dans ma
vie je vais vous voie pour un ami marié
et il vient de rencontrer le jeune femme
et qui voudraient pilote parti en
week-end comment s'appelle votre ami son
prénom il s'appelle comme jean jean
claude
jusqu'au jour où j'ai rencontré mon
beau-père tonton jean claude g or et ma
belle-mère coucou maman ce sera le
troisième anniversaire de notre mariage
ce week-end je n'ose même pas là a bon
dos
[Musique]
flo commence à me poser plein de
questions qu'est ce que je vais faire
c'est la nuit ne voulait pas encore dit
mais j'ai dit
si c'est pas un pli congo in her de
taureaux tu t'arrêtes tu peux tenir
jusqu'à la plus en forme et bakool et à
ça depuis longtemps
[Musique]
12h10
et à genre le prix de la panne est tout
la voiture est vraiment pas mais si ça
et mes seins c'est des vrais
là
mais c'est quoi chanter mais d'accord
qu'on arrête la mission qu'on n'arrête
rien du tout vous voulez dire j'ai cassé
le carreau
je voudrais pas de bosser ça va c'est ce
que c'est ton problème tu sais pas
mentir je veux dire toute la vérité aux
bouchers faut passer si tu prends il
encore rien dit pas pardon
[Musique]